good morning believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in your potential and I want
to see that great thing that you have
inside you explode out into the world
and have a big impact so to help you on
your journey today's message is just
start over to you Mark Zuckerberg ideas
don't come out fully formed they only
become clear as you work on them you
just have to get started if I had to
know everything about connecting people
before I got started I never would have
built Facebook movies and pop culture
just get this all wrong the idea of a
single Eureka moment is a dangerous lie
it makes us feel inadequate because we
feel like we haven't had ours yet and it
prevents people with seeds of good ideas
from ever getting started in the first
place
ideas don't come out fully formed I
really loved when he said that and it's
so true because what happens when you
come with an idea you guys are
entrepreneurs and want to be
entrepreneurs you've all had ideas
whether it's 2:00 in the morning or
you're in the shower or you're on your
way to somewhere and like this is such a
good idea right what happens you know
you write it down you might send a note
for yourself but what often happens is
the next day we wake up and we want to
tell somebody we tell our spouse we tell
our friends we tell the family we tell
the people around us and a lot of times
what happens is people just start to
poke holes right
they might poke holes in the idea itself
like well that's not gonna work because
of all these 18 reasons why they poke
holes on you say well you're never gonna
be able to do that because of all these
18 reasons people tend to poke holes in
things and it's because the idea isn't
fully formed like give me a break I just
came up with it last night it's not
perfect well all too often we take that
feedback and then we say oh they're
right yeah these are all the reasons why
it won't work out or like yeah they're
right I can't do all these things I
don't have those resources and skill
sets and I'm not good enough to be able
to
do that and then the idea dies where it
might have been a great idea it could've
been a world-changing idea it had a huge
impact for you your family your
community the people around you but you
didn't do it because other people said
it wasn't a good idea but the idea
didn't come out fully formed and
standing up to that and saying thank you
that's great feedback
let me improve it like okay that's a
whole thank you for showing me that
whole let's fix it and you're best
friends and people who really help and
support you will be the ones who help
you find the holes but also help you
find the solutions not just pointing out
all the reasons why something's not
gonna work out those are the people you
want to surround yourself with the
people who can point out the flaws not
just tell you that things are gonna be
great like that's a great idea go for it
that's great too positive encouragement
the people who can see the flaws and
then help you find solutions say this is
gonna be a problem how about this as a
solution right those are the people you
want to surround yourself with to help
you take that idea and make it fully
formed so it's not just this thing
that's half-baked that then you abandon
it starts off half-baked and you just
gotta cook it a little bit longer does
it mean that that pie is not gonna work
you just cook it a little bit longer and
you have a scenes of a great idea too
often as well we are our own worst enemy
you come with this idea at 2:00 in the
morning it's fantastic and then the next
day you wake up and tell yourself that
it's a stupid idea that you're not able
to do it that you don't have the
resources that here are all these
problems with it and that I think even
more than outside forces because when
you really believe in something when you
with your whole heart really believe
that this is a great idea it's something
you really want to do you don't care
what other people think something you
need to put them down and tell them
they're stupid right just it's a shield
like it doesn't it doesn't bother you
and so you need to be your own supporter
your own cheerleader and the fastest way
that I found to be able to make that
happen is once I get an idea to take
some kind of immediate action on it once
you get an idea for something that you
want to try do something about it don't
wait until tomorrow like even the next
morning like if it's 2:00 a.m. great
idea boom sleep wake up the next day
poof it's gone
that energy that momentum right like it
could have been four hours of sleep it's
gone that four hour window you just lost
right in that four hour window sleeping
you just lost and it's not that you need
to stay up all night do something even
if it takes five minutes if it's sending
an email to somebody if it's doing some
research do something take that thing
that's a seed of an idea and do
something with it take some kind of
action birth it into the world a little
bit so that when you wake up the next
day there's a little bit of momentum
like send an email to somebody to book a
time to go over a meeting to talk about
it right that person's going right back
to the next day like okay that's
momentum even if you're doubting
yourself you set up that meeting now so
you have to go and talk about it
whenever you get an idea don't let it
die and sit there as an idea forever
immediately take some kind of action to
move it forward
understanding that the initial idea
never comes out fully formed you need to
just start so the question they today is
I'm curious what is one thing that you
are putting off that you have an idea
for a new business or something to add
to your current company it's a great
idea and you just haven't done anything
with it yet that you need to start what
is that thing leaving the comments below
and by leaving it and writing it down I
want you to unleash it to give yourself
permission to actually do something on
it today to get momentum and move that
ball forward leave it down below I also
want to give a quick chart a to
salvatore Vento thank you so much
Salvatore for picking up a cup of my
book your one word I really appreciate
the support and I hope you enjoyed the
read so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot events preso
more expresso give me go
in 2002 let's talk about that initiation
of the dream how did that start and
how'd that come about I'd started a
business before that I raised four
million bucks of other people's money
started a web marketing company went
boom and bust with the first dot-com
boom and bust I knew I wanted to make it
as an entrepreneur and start another
business but I had no idea what I wanted
to do and so for inspiration I went
surfing and I planned a five-month surf
trip around Australia and Indonesia the
inspiration came before I even left I
wanted to capture photos of myself and
my friends that I was going on the trip
with while we were surfing out in the
water and no camera existed that allowed
you to do that and so I set out to
develop this wrist harness that I could
put a single-use disposable camera into
and surf with it and if I didn't even
mean it to be a business idea
I just wanted to document my experience
on this trip and as soon as I got it
working well the light bulb went off and
I realized oh my god there must be so
many other surfers in the world that
want something like this so you started
with wrist straps essentially but how do
you go from wrist straps which are very
simple to Hardware in to actually
developing a camera I wanted to use
higher quality cameras with my wrist
strap to capture higher quality photos
but every camera that I would use with
the strap surfing I would break the
camera because cameras weren't designed
to be used during rigorous activities
like surfing and what I ended up doing
was I spent two years going to trade
shows the camera trade shows around the
world to look for a camera that was
close to what I would want to design
after a year and a half about a year I
found it and got the manufacturer to
agree to make the modifications and
begin building the cameras for me I
actually did the deal without ever
meeting the actual company is all email
I had one phone call where we could
barely understand each other because of
language barrier
in Shenzhen I wired my $5,000 for the
tool to be the to be the mold to be made
because it was it was actually cheaper
just to wire five grand than to fly over
there meet them have a business trip and
I just figured okay we'll just go for it
and they ended up being legitimate and
we were profitable from day one because
it was just me one employee we just had
no overhead and rolled one good
production run into another and slowly
scaled it and the GoPro that that
everybody knows today has been built on
two hundred and sixty-five thousand
dollars of capital because the resources
had been so limited for so long there
were a lot of people who would say God
if I only had access to a camera I would
make a movie there's a lot of talk about
I remember when I was in college I spend
most of my time in my room writing
screenplays really bad screenplays but I
was in my room doing that when I prize
should have been studying or something
there were a lot of people I remember at
parties who would talk about writing and
that they wanted to be writer but I
would always notice they were out every
time I would happen to go out they would
always be out and they I just know that
that there are people who talk about
what they would do if but they're not
actually doing the thing and so it's a
lot easier to actually write a
screenplay than you think it is might
not be good but most people talk about
writing screenplays but don't actually
write them the people who write them
you're already like in you know the top
10 percent because you actually have
written it kind of cliche it but just do
it a lot of time is spent thinking about
something
yeah talking about it you know but when
you actually get something down there on
paper or in code or you know in front of
someone that's when things start
happening and you're going to make a lot
of mistakes the important thing is that
you make decisions and you keep moving
forward but you have to get it out there
yeah you have to start and you have to
be brave enough to to take the criticism
may I always go back to the punk
movement from the 70s mm-hmm people
would get out and be on the street says
you were a teenager back then yeah well
and they say there would be a there
would be learning in front of people and
like they get out on the street and it's
the first time with a guitar yeah and
you know they're learning how to play
and they're getting better and better
and better
yeah and I think that's really important
to just get it down do it just do it it
[Music]
volume you yeah the most important work
ever if you had to think of one word
that's most important to you or that
sums you Apple that would be like a
little beacon hey believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details